Alright
I'm driving to my house going home about two hours earlier here than usual
Because I am going to help take care of my son
Did- Did we did we find out what the point of the video is?
Today, i'm gonna tell you the story about how I finally... became an adult
*Sam yelling to the heavens* "Yeaaaaah
*Corridor Crew Mechanical Intro Sounds*
How do you know when you've become an adult
that's a question I've been asking myself for a very long long time.
In my life i've seen a lot of things that- *baby cries*
*Chuckle* That certainly points towards me being an adult
We created a YouTube channel that was
successful successful enough to grow
Be more than a couple guys working in their apartment now a whole studio of at least 10 guys All creating things they love
That's that's pretty adult like. I finally bought my own home, which was crazy
Having a kid is supposed to make you like an adult
But at the same time there's still plenty of things I do that point the other direction. I love staying up late
I love playing with nerf guns and airsoft guns and shooting them in the office irresponsibly. I like drivin' my car fast
I like shooting off illegal fireworks. I love swinging out swords and maces out in the yard.
So i'm trying to think, okay well
I got these things that make me an adult and these things that kind of point away from it
And so I'm kind of going all right. Well, what is it? What is it exactly?
I'm starting to realize it's not what you do that makes you an adult it's how you do it
so after watching tacticool reloads
You probably think that I can basically juggle guns and reload them with my eyes shut mags flying everywhere
Well turns out, that's not true.
So this is obviously an impossible physical feat?
*Music and mags hitting floor*
Smoked
*Abrupt laughter*
*Gun woosh*
Twinsies
I'm gonna reveal a little bit of the magic trick behind this video why we broke down the shots
The way we did how we actually did these shots and how we can, you can string these together in an edit to make it look
Like you're doing some incredible stuff
If you're trying to do impossible moves, break it down into doable parts and for the few points where it gets really hard to like figure
Out how you're gonna hide something with the cut when in doubt just get really stylized
Which is a great way to get around your weaknesses
Let's walk through it in this video. I do a craazy reload, I take my gun
I launch the mag, flip a new one up in my hand catch it toss my gun in the air and do a 360
Grab it like this toss the mag bounce off my knee slam a gun onto the mag
Toss the gun behind my back catch it. And then I'm done
So this is obviously an impossible physical feat maybe if you practice for years you could do it
But I only had one day.  So here's how I did it
Tossing the mag, easy enough, just push the mag release like *Loud Sneeze* flinging the gun forward.
Sorry Bless you
Thank you
*Short Laughter*
That's an easy way to break a mag
So we actually had to dudes with a blanket standing right there and I'm flinging the mag into the blanket trying not to hit them
Niko : Next up
Adrienne : Insert
Niko : What is an insert shot Adrienne?
An insert shot usually where you can concentrate on an action that you might have otherwise not seen if you want to like clearly show something go grab an
Insert. for this specific moment, which is a close-up of Niko removing a mag from his belt strap which cuts into another shot
like flipping
Important thing with a moment like this. There's a lot of things happening really fast. So in a way you're
Repeating moments individually or focusing on moments individually
That really help enhance the action and it makes them move slower than it would in real life also
You notice that this shot cuts before I catch it
Hard to catch we cut to another insert and this specific shot. We were using black thread
It's just it's attached to the top of a little piece of black tape
So it's lowering into my hand and I'm doing a very over-the-top
Curling my fingers around it
So I toss the gun up in the air once again notice we cut before it comes back down or anything else happens
In real life I literally just throw the gun in the air and start spinning and I just let it let it drop
Hopefully not on my head, and in this shot
This shot works really. It's a black string held taut. I'm just spinning the gun
and i'm literally just spinning underneath it as fast as I can and that's all that's happening. It's the entire shot
and it's important to know your
your actions like how you're getting into the shot and how you're getting out of the shot so that you can be
So that you can be
Overlapping those actions to give you some editing room
So you'll notice I start to reach for it there
Which makes it feel really natural when I catch it and makes it feel like less of a cheat
You always want to feel like you're continuing the motion into the next shot
You actually cut before I catch it too. So I catch the gun a little wonky and then it's really clean. I believe that shot
I just started like this and went
Fake grab it two things when you're editing motion like this. Keep in mind the eye will be drawn to the thing
That's moving the most in the shot
So if when one shot I'm starting to raise my hand and then the next shot i'm continuing to raise my hand that will guide
Your eye other things don't even have to match exactly as long as that motion is continuing. you pay attention to where you're looking that
one shot where I'm reaching up to catch the gun when it's on the string. I'm making eye contact with it
so the next shot I need to be looking at the same target and
You are using where I'm looking as a cue for where you should be looking
Otherwise, it's a little tiny black object on a dark background
it can be hard to follow. I toss the mag up, but I actually knee it and-
Carmichael: Wait you did?
Niko: Mhm
Carmichael: I thought that was VFX
Niko and Adrienne: Nope, this is real.
I got as close as I could
I mean the ideas that we try to take that hard moment and make it the easiest it can be which was the just go
in slow motion
And just do that shall I recreate it? Yeah, there we did that. Well, I was like this
ready and
*Dramatic whisper yell* I basically held the gun there and Adrienne just went like this
*Pop noise*
So this flip here if you want to watch how it looked before we cut it
Here's the raw. just tosses it and we didn't really necessarily needed him to catch it. We had a pad pretty close
I might add to actually that was pretty
Dude that was really close and if you look you can see how close we are to the ground
He was actually kneeling
Cause we didn't want to ruin the gun
You can see my boot! Yeah with you kneeling on the ground
Carmichael: Now how'd you get that shot though?
We dropped it, no string you just dropped it into his hand.
He actually kept it caught it took me a couple tries
We could afford a couple tries and it's a small move like that
and the reason we're low is so that when I missed it, it didn't break and that's
And that's kinda how the whole thing went down
Yeah, so if you're trying to do impossible moves break it down into doable parts and the hard things like catching something I guess are like
Being or like a really precise
Landing of something save those for inserts or cutaways and just make sure your motion is moving into it and out of it
Correctly
And for the few points where it gets really hard to like figure out how you're gonna hide something with the cut like a magazine going
Into the gun when in doubt just get really stylized, which is a great way to get around your weaknesses
*Airsoft shot sound*
*Adrienne in pain and Niko snickering*
But always treat guns like they're loaded bewhzj-jesus chr-
Alright, Kinda feel like we're approaching some decisions we have to make here
My time is starting to get very very divided. We're talking about movies. We're talking about the beast
How do we accomplish this the script for the beast done?
We're going to start making it but at the same time
Things on YouTube are picking up faster than ever. If Clint with you. We have Adrian in the office
They're so talented to do one place being a goal
I had eight years ago to make an independent feature film and the other goal which is well like we built this
Successful YouTube studio. That's just churning out awesome videos, and I want to be a part of both. eight years ago
We started making YouTube videos and it went pretty well
But after doing them for eight years
We know making videos like we know the backs of our hands at this point was just last week film the video that we planned
and scripted the night before we have some figuring out to do on set but that's pretty comfortable going into it because I knew it'd
Been through before we've done this process and things will go well, but well
How do I say this, as an artist you face struggles
You're in a creative space and when you are kind of defined by how creative you can get
The more you do one thing over and over and over again
Well, it starts to kind of impede a little bit on that creativity
I want to make this very clear very very clear because this might come out the wrong way
I want to make this very clear YouTube is our life because ultimately you are
special and what we have going on here this thing this is this is
Incredible and anyone who would abandon this or give this up as you complete more what I'm talking about?
I'm talking about adding more fruit to the table the table that you share with us. The world has a big and scary place
It's okay to be in sure. It's okay to not know what you're doing
Five ten fifty years from now that can change and evolve and morph into something
Even better than what you expected. Of course everybody wants to be happy and everybody wants to
Be successful
What's defined all of my decisions like being 22 and moving to LA, it's not about defining or like going after what makes you happy?
It's defining your deal-breakers. Now I'm at like my peak
Happiness realizing that you take every day at a time
Everything at a time. Everything is temporary
You would never know. What makes you happy
If you don't figure out what doesn't work for you exactly
How I felt when we got married was I had a really humbling moment like we woke up the next morning
I had like a fantastic night you were there
The-the wedding, that was, she's talking about the wedding.
*Everyone laughing*
You were at the wedding AT THE WEDDING
That was that part of the night
*More laughter*
It is a humbling feeling to realize that somebody just committed to spend their life with you. my expectations for
What our baby would be like I mean
I thought he would be more of a baby and I thought that I would be like running the show he arrives
And it turns out that like he's your boss and you're just doing the best you can. fun fact about babies
We all used to be babies. A lot of you guys probably don't care much about babies and I agree
You don't get babies and the family life stuff until it really happens to you
So whatever but all you parents out there and people with babies you get it. It's awesome
Babies are sweet is accountability and responsibility right now his have an all-time low. All he's got to do is stay alive
I mean, I think the only thing he's capable of doing by him Oh a little smile
Yeah
That's right. I'm-ta-This is something I'm proud of him
Yeah, eheheh
Heheh
Helwa. he's pretty and the one thing he does really really well by himself
Is he poops his pants by himself all by himself
He just poops and pees and then doesn't it never ends and talking about you. I'm proud of ya and
Anyways when I moved to Los Angeles in
2009 to kind of start my big career my
Expectations were kind of like all right gonna figure this whole thing out
We're gonna make movies, you know, I got to get a girlfriend. It's it's the whole thing
I'm sitting there just a dude a young dude early 20s in LA
I-I you know honestly
I had really no idea how my personal life was gonna go alongside this whole like moviemaking career
And so I was just playing that by year, but I met Sarah things we hit it off
It was great suddenly we're like boyfriend and girlfriend and now suddenly we're getting married
and like I'm just like this is not how I was expecting this to go getting married and stuff look like it's been
incredible and I wouldn't trade it for the world and I'm suddenly
Baby Gideon is in our lives and he's the best and he's so cool. And I've got the highest hopes and dreams for him
But before we had baby Gideon, whatever you want to do something you go out and do it
There's nothing stopping you. the only people we had to worry about were ourselves
there wasn't this feeling of like true accountability because suddenly now when you have a child didn't really realize we would have to
change our life and start making our decisions with our
new family in mind how do we make decisions that really benefit everyone here just like this morning I wake up and I'm like
Okay. Well, here's the things I got to do
I have some free time here between all my chores and taking care of the baby
It's like do I play a video game for 20 minutes? Like how is that going to affect everything?
well
If I do this will I not be able to clean the dishes if I don't do the dishes I have to go to work
And then Sarah's going to do them in the middle of the day while juggling the baby like oh my go-
It's like suddenly it's like this whole like Ripple wait  minute, baby Gideon
Did we did we find out what the point of the video is?
Did we realize what it means to be an adult?
*Music*
Being an adult is all about being accountable for every decision you make because you know that it's going to affect everyone around you like
Sarah or baby Gideon
or baby, Nick and Carmichael
Am I an adult?
Sometimes!
Yes!
And cut!
*Laughter*
*Boop*
*Fake slow motion sounds*
Keep it rolling keep it rolling!
*Boop*
*Laughter*
Dadyouorsomething
*Boop*
*Short Boop*
*Laughter*
*Boop*
Smoked
*Adrienne Laughs*
Adrienne!
*Boop*
Smoked
*Tries to spit it out*
*Laughter*
*Boop*
Right
And action
*Boop*
*There aren't any more boops*
*Except for that last one*
*I mean, er*
*Boop*